[Música]
Colombia y Guatemala llamaron a
consultas a sus embajadoras a causa del
proceso que la fiscalía guatemalteca
prevé abrir contra Iván Velázquez actual
ministro de defensa de Colombia y quien
fue presidente de la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad en
Guatemala lo acusan de corrupción
vinculada con odebrecht
el gobierno peruano aseguró que se
prepara para la llegada de miles de
manifestantes que marchan hacia lima y
que prevén una toma de la ciudad los
ciudadanos van llegando a la capital
tras semanas protestando para pedir la
renuncia de la mandataria la disolución
del Congreso y el adelanto de elecciones
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos emitió un comunicado en el que
condenó el uso excesivo de la fuerza
durante las protestas que ya cumplen
varias semanas en Bolivia justamente los
manifestantes levantaron los bloqueos
para la huelga nacional convocada para
el 25 de enero ampliamos desde La Paz
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio
con la atención que enfrenta a Colombia
y Guatemala el presidente guatemalteco
Alejandro yamatei cargó contra su
homólogo colombiano Gustavo Petro y
aseguró que está cometiendo El error de
un guerrillero al tiempo que lo calificó
de poco político ambos gobiernos
llamaron a consultas a sus embajadoras
luego de que la fiscalía guatemalteca
anunciaron proceso contra Iván Velázquez
actual ministro de defensa de Colombia y
expresidente de la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad en
Guatemala sisic según las autoridades
guatemaltecas de las que se abuso de su
poder al aprobar acuerdos de cooperación
supuestamente anómalos con dos
directivos brasileños de odebrecht en
2017 Ramiro cuevar berena tiene los
detalles
el choque diplomático es un hecho
embajadoras convocadas versiones
cruzadas entre presidentes y
funcionarios que temen una posible
ruptura de las relaciones bilaterales la
atención va en aumento entre Colombia y
Guatemala la razón las acciones legales
que la fiscalía especial guatemalteca
anunció que iniciaría contra Iván
Velázquez actual ministro de defensa
colombiano y antiguo director de la
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala respaldada por
Naciones Unidas la fiscalía especial
contra la impunidad emprenderá las
acciones legales correspondientes para
que respondan por sus actos ilegales
arbitrarios y abusivos el ex comisionado
de la comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala Sisi Iván
Velázquez Gómez y la ex funcionaria de
sisic Luz Adriana Camargo garzón
el fiscal Rafael currucciche apunta que
Velázquez debe responder por actos
ilegales arbitrarios y abusivos por la
recepción de sobornos en un expediente
corrupción que lo enlaza con la
constructora brasileña odebrecht sin
embargo kurruchiche está en la lista en
el de Estados Unidos acusado de obstruir
investigaciones y desbaratar casos de
corrupción contra altos funcionarios el
caso contra Velázquez provocó el rechazo
de países extranjeros como Estados
Unidos y el repudio del presidente
Gustavo Petro quien catalogó el proceso
como una persecución Y qué lo
defenderemos
él seguirá siendo nuestro ministro
si Guatemala insiste
en apresar hombres justos bueno otros
nada tenemos que hacer
velas que lideró la investigación en
Guatemala que terminó con la división
del presidente Otto Pérez Molina en 2017
quien recibió una condena de 16 años por
corrupto el colombiano fue cesado de la
comisión internacional por decisión Del
mandatario Jimmy Morales que cerró la
entidad en
en sus 11 años de funcionamiento la
comisión impulsó casos que implicaron a
680 personas entre funcionarios y
empresarios ganó 310 condenas y
desmanteló 60 redes criminales en un
país que ha obligado el exilio a cinco
agentes de la ley en tres años Por
investigar a miembros del gobierno en
Perú la Caravana de manifestantes que
salió del Sur del país rumbo a Lima la
capital ha comenzado a llegar al tiempo
que otros ciudadanos avanzan en el
camino a pesar de los bloqueos
policiales los manifestantes protestan
contra el gobierno de la presidenta Dina
boluarte en la cual afirmó que está
lista para dialogar con ellos y pidió
que las movilizaciones se lleven a cabo
en paz
las caravanas de manifestantes siguen su
camino hacia Lima mientras la policía
intenta controlarlos miles de personas
salieron desde varias zonas Rurales del
sur de Perú rumbo a la capital donde
esperan poder hacer escuchar su voz
piden la dimisión de la presidenta Gina
boluarte la disolución del parlamento y
la organización de elecciones inmediatas
estoy emocionado para viajar a Lima
porque la lucha continúa
estamos viajando todos los hermanos
sangre aymara y a la lucha los
manifestantes bloquearon carreteras pero
la policía logró liberar varios tramos
de la Panamericana así como de la vía
interoceánica Este martes la presidenta
pidió a los manifestantes reunirse
pacíficamente a su llegada a Lima
sabemos que quieren tomar Lima por todo
lo que está saliendo en las redes el 18
y el 19
yo los llamo a tomar Lima Sí pero en paz
en calma y los espero en la casa de
gobierno para poder dialogar sobre las
agendas sociales que tiene porque
ustedes bien saben que la agenda
política que están planteando es
inviable desde el ejecutivo el
movimiento de protestas empezó el 7 de
diciembre tras la destitución del
expresidente Pedro Castillo que fue
acusado de un intento de golpe de estado
por intentar disolver el congreso que
iba a reunirse a estudiar su destitución
en medio de acusaciones de corrupción el
gobierno declaró el estado de emergencia
en parte del país para hacer frente a
las protestas que dejan decenas de
Muertos una misión de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
concluyó que había indicios de uso
excesivo de la fuerza por parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad ya se encuentran en
Venezuela los delegados del gobierno
colombiano para reunirse de manera
extraordinaria con los representantes de
la guerrilla del eln el encuentro tiene
lugar en un momento de tensión entre las
partes dado que el presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro afirmó en
diciembre que ese grupo guerrillero
había pactado un cese bilateral del
fuego Por espacio de seis meses una
afirmación que fue desmentida por la
organización sobre este reinicio de las
conversaciones se refirió el embajador
de Colombia en Venezuela Armando
Benedetti
saludamos y le damos la bienvenida a la
delegación de paz del gobierno para los
diálogos con el eln hoy en Caracas
confiamos en que el jefe de la
delegación otipatiño el comisionado de
paz Danilo Rueda José Félix lafoury y
todo el equipo logren Ahora sí una paz
real y duradera Vamos hasta Bolivia
porque la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos condenó la violencia y
cualquier uso excesivo de la fuerza en
las protestas que llevan varias semanas
en el país en rechazo a la detención del
gobernador opositor de la provincia de
Santa Cruz de la Sierra esto al tiempo
que los bloqueos están siendo levantados
porque los manifestantes se preparan
para una gran huelga este 25 de enero
previamente merivaca corresponsal de
France veinticuatro en La Paz nos dio
más detalles del pronunciamiento de la
cidh la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos en conjunto con la
relatoría para la libertad de expresión
han emitido un comunicado en esta
jornada condenando los hechos violentos
durante las protestas realizadas en
Santa Cruz este comunicado condena por
un el uso excesivo de la fuerza por
parte de las fuerzas de seguridad del
Estado pero también la violencia
provocada por grupos civiles el reporte
indica que en Santa Cruz se han
producido enfrentamientos entre la
sociedad civil y los policías dejando
varios heridos y también periodistas
afectados y agredidos por estos
enfrentamientos por otro lado se reporta
que se han registrado alrededor de 25
hechos de vulneraciones a los derechos
humanos en Santa Cruz por el otro lado
la comisión indica que en Santa Cruz los
grupos civiles han arremetido en contra
de instituciones públicas se sabe que a
muchas de ellas han sido quemadas e
incluso una vivienda de un ministro a
resultado afectada por tanto la comisión
y la relatoría para la libertad de
expresión instan al Estado boliviano a
que garantice el derecho a la protesta
de los ciudadanos y además garantice la
protección de los ciudadanos cuando
concurran a estas protestas en
diferentes partes del país
el gobierno de Brasil anunció la
destitución de 40 militares que estaban
encargados de la seguridad de la
residencia oficial del presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva no obstante aclaró
que los agentes seguirán siendo parte de
las fuerzas armadas se trata de
militares de Rango menor que custodiaban
el Palacio de La Alborada y la decisión
llega luego del ataque de Seguidores
bolsonaristas contra las sedes de los
tres poderes en Brasilia el pasado 8 de
enero
en otros temas comenzó en Nueva York que
el juicio contra Genaro García Luna el
ex secretario de seguridad pública de
México inició con la primera jornada
para elegir a las 15 personas del Jurado
entre los 191 preseleccionados la
fiscalía lo acusa de narcotráfico y de
aceptar sobornos del Cartel De Sinaloa a
cambio de facilitar las operaciones del
grupo cuando ocupó el máximo cargo de
seguridad en el país entre 2006 y 2012
por eso García Luna está detenido desde
hace tres años el martes estuvo en la
sala del tribunal Federal del distrito
este de Nueva York junto con sus
abogados
a ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que volvemos en breve con más en France
[Música]